how does it feel making 17 grand on one
deal
uh it just finally like all the people
don't do it this
i find really hard to admit i'm
financially free this is my life
sometimes i will think about it's like
my car broke down so he's like have to
commute and looking at people around he
said this is my life like commuting on
the train
in the next 30 years congratulations for
being here
what made you get into property
um
i have a memory like with my parents a
long time when i was a baby i don't know
okay they wanted really to buy something
but they were asking an uncle to lend
them money and that didn't happen and
then i remember driving around this
place they said you see there was worth
with this and then if now it would be
worth it much more you know they always
like pt
i don't know he stayed with me i don't
know i want to break i really think that
i don't think my parents even know they
always remember this yeah yeah so they
were like if we've only done that and
the numbers are oh my god that makes
sense even i was a kid
were you from italy right yeah so you're
from italy we met a couple years ago and
at the time you were working extremely
hard what were you doing when we met uh
seven days a week
seven yeah seven seven days a week yeah
because well my previous job as an
interior designer was
specialized in soft furnishing was six
days a week but anyway i was working as
any city agents on saturdays but then
when i lost the job i was made redundant
because i carved a lot of people they
lost their jobs uh so i had to work a
little bit more because i found the
estate agent's job i mean it was only
saturday and then i found the only job i
could do like i applied for supermarkets
anyway anyway i got a job as a delivery
for a company and i didn't have a van or
anything so it was my fiat 500 and
everyone was laughing when i arrived
because i was stuck everything just to
make an extra 50 feet one
you know what if you turned up to my
house as a delivery lady it would make
my day yeah i was smiling like you know
i thought about because i saw a lot of
people was quite interesting to see a
lot of people struggling so
also teachers think because i feel a bit
i don't know it was humiliating
sometimes sometimes some family they
were rude and and then but then i saw
people like even teachers things
everyone you know you have to adapt so
you stop and get depressed or you adapt
so i said you know it's fine it's an
adventure one day i will think about
this like you know i still made it
through everyone's gotta make them money
you know so
when did you start seeing my videos um
so i had an opportunity to actually ever
free jobs because i had an opportunity
to do a little design project for a
friend in south kensington so because i
was working this two jobs seven days a
week so at night my old old preview boss
he was so kind that he landed me back
the keys of the office i didn't have a
computer
at the time so he said look when because
of car with the distance you cannot come
during the day maybe come in the
afternoon after five so at night time
between five and like i don't know ten
sometimes eleven like after my other two
jobs i would just go in the office to
use this computer to do this
presentation source for materials for
this girl and then i want the company
because you know an empty office dark is
quite scary so i will put some videos on
and always put property things and then
you came and sometimes like oh my god
this dude was
screaming because in sally sometimes you
were really excited it's like oh my god
what is about
and then also because uh you know
the mental have like the anxious not to
have this job thinking about i'm not
going to do these jobs forever like
running around like i don't know
sometimes when i so started running a
lot to help me through and then i said
okay let's listen to other people about
properties and then let me choose a
podcast and they were the first girls
and the ceo of your company like your
russell your brother and they keep
talking about yeah someone is oh my god
these people they're talking about
samwell again so let me keep listening
to him and see things and then i saw you
where like there were the crash course
things
and then i started to apply but um
yeah it didn't work yeah you i know you
applied for lots of things you signed up
for crash courses you signed up for the
eviction and you were rejected which i'm
really sorry about um however you just
kept going and kept going and i remember
the day when you first registered and
were accepted onto the academy but what
was the what was the in terms of
property in the uk like what what was
the first deal that you did um
so the first one so thanks to the you
know online course which was because we
have to stay home so there was still a
way to interact live yeah a lot of the
training
a lot of the training you did was was it
the mentoring and the training it was
like zoom and stuff yeah before that
actually in june i
actually bought the first course which
was the uh sourcing course because i
said i did always something in
properties um i did a little city agent
so i think i think it's like it could be
good for me because pretty much with the
city agents and
i'm sourcing property for clients
like what is explained
how did you get the money for this was
my last thousand
i never said to anyone to my family
anywhere they will say are you crazy
this guy in youtube is just the last
other yeah and then i didn't have a
computer your first uh i was so proud i
opened on my phone and then he said the
first things you need is the only things
you need is a laptop oops i don't know
what so i had to go at night to my old
office to use it but then i found
decorative we're like asking someone you
know i'll give you later so i got an
ipad
because you know you can do from the
iphone but you have to do the exercise
and things i don't know it's a bit
better yeah
you sold quite a few deals yeah then uh
uh from there like we
there was a crash course finally
happening in december 2020 yeah the
first time i met you for like for a
second tell me about the first deal you
sold so the first ones because a lot of
people they
there was a risk because our airbnb was
all shot and uh because of call with
like a lot of things they were not
moving as a for what you should be like
the rent usa but a lot of people they
were confident that london would
eventually pick up because uh mid-2020 i
think they were about to
uh light up like the restrictions yeah
so people they knew they were aware i
realized landlord they were more
they were easy like they were how do you
say um they learned a lot they were
except maybe lower offers on properties
yeah so it was still a good time uh
people that would be worried what if the
property is empty a month but then i
realized you can get really good deals
so i started to look for rent usa and
then i found a few contacts some there
was a person he knew some landlord some
direct
and then i started to talk to people and
then in advance you gave me to the crash
course i did during like my birthday
month uh the only one i managed to
attend live uh you said uh um just
contact all the investors add value
go online and look for different places
you said actually don't go on website
where you say where they sell a lot of
these just go things about medics you
know like people that have a lot of
money these professions so i google i
joined a lot of groups and then just
listening what people were saying giving
advices
and then yeah during also what i was
doing about running i found a
development in london
from the development in london um
and then there was a lot of research to
do because you need planning permission
and things which stage it was
um but then i was really you started
spotting opportunities then basically in
london
and what was the your first strategy was
your first strategy to find these
opportunities and then to sell them on
um
i've also even yeah i like a lot of
people i think they struggle didn't even
know where to approach the investor how
to talk to that but when i start to talk
you just have to do experience you have
to realize because i was about i don't
know maybe italians to be perfect
perfect how two things some things have
to be wrong at the beginning like no
wrong like you do diligence and things
you have you know new courses you know
what to do what to check but when you
talk is the way it is at the beginning
you might look a little bit silly you
know max and some people they may be
like oh i don't even understand you uh
and then some you know some phone calls
you you like mumble up now graviella
you've gained a reputation in the
academy for being somebody that can not
just sell lots of deals but charge
extremely high finders fees because the
deals that you're selling are extremely
profitable deals so what's the highest
finders fee you've ever been paid um
is about
15
500
15 500 for one deal yeah and that
actually was because you said and then i
realized some people sometimes waste a
little bit of time so i said look
because i have to look for you so i need
to make sure i paid because i knew i had
to pay my expenses the more if i have to
leave a little bit the other two jobs so
i have to be up front like wherever it
happens or not so i pay so you pay me
for two months like no refundable 2000
the first month 2000 the second month
and then we agree anyway before even
that that whatever was the price of the
house it was
we agreed it was one percent anyway it
came up the house was over three million
something so the percentage so was uh
2000 the first month to look february
2000 in march to look and then finally
we found one exchange completed so he
pay me the rest of thirteen thousand
right so when you made that money that
thirteen thousand plus the other two
seventeen grand in total yeah from that
one deal
how did that make you feel in relation
to your other three jobs because you're
working as a as a delivery person or
whatever packaging stuff delivery lady
how does it feel making 17 grand on one
deal
it just finally like all the people
don't do it they
don't know it's like the confidence that
people i don't know how people they can
trust you and then i don't look so
professional like going to the house
showing the
you know
excel spreadsheet this is the
i don't know it's just a new career it
makes you feel funnily like when i um
the last month honestly even when i was
going to interior design job i was
looking around everyone's so sad they
were not even allowed maybe to put music
on they said oh my god it's like you
know i got my age
i've been here is like over something
it's like this is my life sometimes i
will think about this like
my car broke down so it's like i have to
commute and looking at people around is
that this is my life like commuting on
the train
in the next 30 years like oh sitting and
you know say yes i'm working hard i'll
always work unpaid extra hours to finish
projects because it's like oh my god i
would get really anxious like that's it
like because this is my degree that's
what i studied like must be something
more like and then the liberty like i
was going to i decided which hours to
dedicate when to call him uh when to go
to see properties and it's quite you
know you go out and you know and making
someone happy the guy was so happy just
starting to do reference
what have you done with those three jobs
uh well from
some of the friends i made uh mine
because you said surrounded yourself on
people from the summer 365. they say
just leave it but always like
really careful i'm from some of you tell
you so really careful you know you know
don't don't jump in something you so
slowly i asked to the delivery person
like can i do a few days lessons oh
really okay fine then it was one day
less are you still doing are you still a
doctor oh no i stopped uh
some even the second job is
the agent i was so gutted they really
want me to stay did you question
yeah
everything
last summer yeah so what do you do now
i have found really hard to admit i'm
financially free that's why it took me a
year to come here tony greek is like
come you're financially free same night
it's like are you working like no
actively like with the deal source of
course you have to go out there
you're doing
so you're a full-time property
entrepreneur oh yeah how many properties
do you own right now today as we speak
since last week six because i just
completed another one congratulations
what was the last one you completed on
um so was a little property like in the
in the north
needs a little bit refurbishment but i
really love that because how much you
pay for it fifty three thousand fifty
three yeah and and you're gonna do it up
and then before no yeah not too much and
we finance and probably i'm still in
this idea i might leave maybe someone a
good family for a couple of years or
something yeah because
i don't need to rush what's your most
profitable deal that you've got right
now the past the passive income deal
well i got rent from other like uh nsa
london i go rent and then how much is it
uh
is never empty it's like 99 percent
occupancy like i have to keep putting
the price up because it's just crazy
like how easy it gets booked up um
it till it's like three thousand a month
so i know the
expenses i got about
really gross always to you know you say
make it one thousand one hundred but
actually one thousand expenses so two
thousand
sometimes december when it was i even
put higher because wow i just check
whatever is uh so you've got your
properties you've got your portfolio
you've got your deal selling when was
the last time you sold a deal last week
and then another one was last month the
end of it and how much did you make on
those each of them
my fee is always pretty much 2190.
okay cool which again just on that side
alone that's full time yeah and then
you've got your properties so you're now
a really good earner
yeah you look fantastic how have you
changed as a person
oh my god it's like i know people i hope
really hope that people understand how
important is
uh the freedom like i do some issues
with my family last year and when i was
like
uh a way kind of working just passive
income you sit there it's like
everyone's stressing out you know your
family or whatever your friends are
work always like i have to go to work
it's like and some people sometimes ask
me but you don't have to go back to work
like no i work on my computer it's like
in social media it's like you know i'm
talking to investors or sometimes they
see me like consume call in a bedroom on
the corner like uh oh can you tell now
it's really serious oh you're just
having a chat no no it's not chat this
is work this is a zoom call chat with
investors that's my job i don't need to
do it it's unreal like you can decide
when you go away you don't have to ask
like in my old job filling a form hoping
they give you the holidays but it's not
about the holidays the freedom like i
needed to be there like someone in my
family was no well you can just go yeah
like you don't have to justify and still
uh you can do the saucy like i go every
few weeks to check a few areas which are
my target all the time because i know
them really well but then you can go
back you know their flights all the time
so you trains i don't even drive there
because i like quite in the train
because you keep working on the computer
i feel like so
it's relaxing they don't even have to
get worried or drive you know the yeah
the risk is like
and you've done all this just in the
space of maybe 18 months two years yeah
i haven't really systemized that's a
really important thing i'm learning like
systemize putin i keep saying to tonic i
don't know how much i'm making because i
have to put in excel but it's so real
like the first time when i was in a live
zoom call i think was february
2021 last year so i was generally have
to take some money the and i saw
like
the alert from lloyd's coming coming
money and then you look at the last
system the last two weeks they were like
two thousand five hundred three thousand
three times about like two thousand it's
like these are deals and the total from
last month being something a bank
account the outcome is 15 000 again
to actually refund it but they were
already sourcing so then there was a
live mastermind i think you invited me
still online actually
and then you asked me i said just today
i just checked my bank account i just
said in a few weeks i made
i the time i made i think was
about 15 000. i had to refund two
sometimes you know people change their
mind and then i'm happy like to keep the
friendship like this uh so nine thousand
i made and then that day
uh there was why don't you join the
academy but it's like it was still
online because everything was uh shut
due to covet so i used to be only the
online course and i i really enjoyed the
sourcing course because of them at the
beginning i just invested in 995
because you can go back there
you know you read again your own time
so i said i was working the city i
decided to hide in the bathroom so i was
in the bathroom toilet a little toilet
and then try to call one of your guys to
book the online uh the academy the
online academy she's like i mean i'm
giving the credit card details it's like
um
between viewings like oh my god i'm not
gonna lose this opportunity because
i really understood how wherever you
earn you have to bring back some to
education
because yeah okay it's good to see a
chunk but the chunk of money will finish
with only those things there will always
be an emergency so better to reinvest
something and then did you decide you
know what how big is the stack for me at
the beginning i had about a thousand and
i felt a bit crazy but i understood it
really made sense of the sourcing course
and actually improved
like in theory like i didn't really pay
for the academy or the course because i
made all in deals so it's really my
money and also not only will you make
the money about but you can also climb
back the academy as a business expense
yeah i had just talked to my oh to my
account in the microphone uh yeah he was
saying that i'm doing all sorted out
because i opened in the company because
the beginning everyone i see they stress
out they don't and i did the same they
don't move ahead they don't do the next
step but just go into the viewing they
say i want to do my company slowly it's
like no start to do it and as you said
you can legally you know you have to do
properly but you could source with
someone who's at the beginning i even do
that core sourced and then i did my
company and and pretty much then i
didn't have to use again also for the
company a few fees i used the sourcing
then manual but i was called sourcing
what's been the biggest challenge
graziella over the last few years
um
[Music]
i'm really grateful there was the 365
and the friends i made
like patricia gemma kenny
camille adam
because to keep focus i don't know if
it's only me but we can procrastinate or
get shy of
you know
not to do the steps not to do the phone
call or maybe you do for a period and
then it will always be a period you
really beat yourself oh my god these
moms haven't made any if you haven't
done anything and maybe you just leave
it instead no he said you know it's okay
life sometimes you slow down keep going
just continue and then when you have
these people uh around you or it's not
just them also yourself like you're
available i don't know how you do with
so many people like always amazing you
you generally pick up the phone and
reply really straight away to people uh
i mean at the tony crook and uh david
taylor's like um generally all the times
but i'm really i would never forget the
christmas days because i really was
selling a lot another development deals
in the both of them yeah call me and say
okay let's keep it brief no no christmas
there was are you kidding me because so
many investors ask me okay
they were asking me some things like
should i just pick up a half piece or
something did you sell a deal on
christmas day
a couple of days yeah
and it was a person in uh the time i was
just asked someone everyone asked can
you do the source in part
the academy mentors were taking calls on
christmas day uh yeah i felt like so
embarrassed but then a few months before
because i met them
they said don't be just call don't worry
because the first months i haven't
really used the calls because i was shy
i don't know don't want to bother but
then when you get to use it they're so
helpful it's like i'm sorry i have to
call them well
and thanks to them
personally linkedin bless him he trusted
me because you know i guess i show from
what i study like
i
he signed was fifteen thousand and at
the end like he came to visit the site
he was not really don't know convince
business parties jb was not convinced
for the course thing so they they get a
refund after 13 days which is fine but
then again it was a boost because you
told me i sent you a message well
probably would be refunded say it's not
about that you have to focus you got
like you managed to sell it yeah so you
you still had the professional approach
with someone you don't know he didn't
even meet you in person but he sent you
money he just saw your link there i mean
there's a lot of money so it means like
he saws i understood like you knew what
you were talking about and just the
system i just got you from the course is
the training yeah well you've done
really well and you've not only that but
i think you're such an asset to the
academy because you bring so much light
and joy and everybody everybody loves
you everybody speaks highly of you
how important is it to have friends that
are also
in the industry helping you out pulling
you up as well as mentors but how
important is friends
it's vital and unfortunately you have to
decide to leave behind some old friends
because of bring you down i mean family
for example you can't do that because
they in that case they try to protect
you so i even even told
yesterday i bought
one last week because it was worried and
things so
the the people they're doing the same
things they will find the same
challenges so they will give you the
advice maybe
what i understand is why aren't you
friends why aren't people's friends and
families worried when when their friends
are working seven days a week
three jobs suffering with depression
because of it then the friends and
family just think oh fine no problem but
then as soon as you say
actually i'm gonna get into property
suddenly everyone's freaking out what's
what's that about
i had to say i was i don't know like
even though everyone knew about like all
the issues i had i keep pretending oh no
just call it i will get my job back and
the meantime was like running
but i have to say they want to protect
family because my family generally is
really lovely they want to protect and
and they're worried in case financial
i'm not able to pay back or whatever the
mortgages and things
and then when they hear like oh buff
someone from youtube you know there's so
many people out there how can you trust
someone from youtube for them if someone
i think a lot of generations are not
still used to the social media actually
now is really powerful it's just a
really quick uh you know place to get
information but then of course you can
pick some information but you have to go
deep into you have to do the courses
like otherwise
yeah i still see people commenting
lately when you take um youtube like oh
you can just do yourself you can't
really uh because we get really wrong
information the people the panel of
people that help you they're
professional so that's why i have to
call like on a christmas day because
straight away they don't do that don't
do that
you know if they don't know the answer
they will get back to you
but they've been there before
the family i think yeah just to protect
you the only things i tried sometimes to
make a scheme to show them what is rent
to rent why why invest in this money why
that is a good things i don't know
they're still being scared of things
like what are they right now they're
still scared or they know sometimes they
still make comments i come back guys
like for example i had an expense like
something broke in the house we were
talking about like 50 like a little
things say oh why don't you sell these
things so much you know so much pain and
all this checking all the times like
yeah there's a little bit more effort in
the essay you have to check in uh you
know more often but it's like
because i haven't shared exactly how
much i'm making it's like
yeah but it's fine seventy because a lot
you know in a five days time this
california family he paid 880 to come
and this 70 was something to adjust it's
like it's fine like because the normal
residential rent won't make that money
so it's like no you don't see the big
pictures like yeah sometimes i feel like
some people friends have been jealous to
be honest they don't want to say i don't
like every my friends they're nice
i think i think a bit jealous not even
because i don't really see exactly how
much money i'm making of things i still
actually figure out writing down i'm
doing my tax uh but i think because they
maybe they don't have inclination they
never thought about profit so maybe uh
they know how is their life they're
gonna be stuck for 40 years wherever to
go to the office to commute a lot of
people they love living beautiful houses
but you know central london you have to
commute so they still that those people
be in the train every day so it's like
yeah wherever like not to feel like oh
how she's in olivia or she's uh you know
working a few days and she's okay it's
like uh
and they're comfortable i mean i don't
wanna say but
i mean came like a blessing in this guy
so also anytime something bad happens i
know it's hard to see the bigger picture
but kovit came i mean i lost the job i
had a mortgage a car to pay like so many
things
um
i don't know and then you have you push
yourself it's good it's good when you're
struggling i mean i know it's strange to
say but when you struggle then you find
the creativity you push yourself you do
more phone call you go move you because
you're so hungry you have to do s to
happen yeah so i don't know how does it
feel now looking back on all you've
achieved over the last couple of years
uh well in my goal i think here the
course at the beginning he said set your
goals it was like being a winner and a
wednesday but it was one of these
dreams
then i realized it's a dream by the
dream that became you know you came
through like wow it's like dream that
you become true and what's your
strongest reason for doing this um
[Music]
generally is the power of the freedom
it's unbelievable the freedom that you
can
uh help someone can be family friends it
can be financial financially or
they need something some support you
have more time you can be there
physically you can organize your time
like i don't know it's
it's really like something got feeling
like you don't have to go at seven
o'clock go to work and deal with these
clients you pick your clients you know
sometimes they're difficult like the
source say you know what take your
feedback that's it once actually your
mom said um
i think she told me
imagine like there is a
a bird so you give them some some seeds
so you don't want to force it if they
come to you i don't remember what the
analogy right so just pick because they
don't if you chase the birds they'll run
away yeah you hold the bread and let
them come to you yeah yeah
yeah i said just you know the one they
delay just whatever let them go so you
decide that's a dream like you decided
you want to work with because before was
my boss of course they decided so you
know you get stuck with a client no it's
like i decide like ah
what's it been like working with me for
the last two years
oh my god they're like sometimes i
really feel like i want to cry because
sometimes i've physically tried to go
back to my photos these stories to see
the steps because it's really easy to re
forget all the steps and i realize all
the time there are videos of you like
you put a post above me a video uh you
know always encourage you say something
mentioning uh small messages when i
and then yeah like uh and all the
network behind you is like it's like
it's not like this guy sold the the
course and then it disappeared wherever
you know he's been really present and
um the yeah the motivation you really
need to have it is probably the most
important things you may be missing of
things or skills so but you will have
some skills but you have to you know
whatever you have make it work yeah
coming on here today and sharing your
story and letting your light shine is a
great thing to do so well done and i
look forward to helping you continue in
your property journey thank you well
done
[Music]